Most of what we do these days,
our methods or theories or ideas are shaped to some extent by Piaget's
influence.
And so what I want to do is begin this class is going to talk about cognitive
development by talking about his ideas.
Um,
his idea was the children are active thinkers.
They're trying to figure out the world.
He often described him as little scientists,
um,
and incidentally to know where he's coming from on this,
he had a very dramatic and ambitious goal.
He didn't start off because he was interested in children.
He started off cause he's interested in emergence of knowledge in general.
Um,
it was a discipline he described as genetic epistemology,
the origins of knowledge,
but he studied development of the individual child because he was convinced that
this development will tell them,
but the development of knowledge more generally,
there's a very snooty phrase that,
I don't know if you've ever heard it before.
It's a great phrase.
It's ontogeny,
recapitulates,
phylogeny.
And the idea of this,
what that means is that development of an individual mimics our repeats,
development of the species.
Now,
it's entirely not true,
but it's a beautiful phrase.
And Piaget was committed to this.
He was very interesting.
Look,
we'll figure how to kid develops and now I will tell us about the development of
knowledge more generally.
So the [inaudible] view the child as science,
as a scientist who develop these understanding,
these schemas,
these little miniature theories of the world,
and they did this through two sorts of mechanisms,
assimilation and accommodation.
So assimilation would be the act of expanding the range of things that you
respond to.
Piaget's example would be a baby is used to sucking on a breast,
might come to suck on a bottle or on a rattle.
That's changing the scope of things that you respond to.
Accommodation is changing how you do it.
A baby will form his mouth differently depending on what he's sucking on.
And so these processes where you take in,
I've given this in a very physical way,
but in a more psychological says,
you have a way of looking at the world.
You could expand it to encompass new things,
assimilation,
when you could also change your system of knowledge itself.
Accommodation and Piaget argue that these two mechanisms of learning drove the
child through different stages.
Um,
and he had a stage theory which was quite different from the Floridian stage
theory that we've been introduced to.
So it was methods,
um,
were to ask question,
told them to solve problems and I asked him questions and his discoveries that
they did them in different ways at different ages led to the emergence of the
stage theory.
So for Piaggi,
the first stage
is the sensory motor stage or to sensory motor period.
Um,
for here the child is purely a physical creature.
The child has no understanding in any real way of the external world.
There's no understanding of the past,
no understanding of the future,
no stability,
no differentiation.
Uh,
the child just touches and cs but doesn't yet reason.
And it's through this stage that the child gradually comes to acquire object
permanence.
Object permanence is the understanding that things exist when you no longer see
them.
So those of you in front,
you're looking at me,
then I go
and occurred to me.
It'd be a great magic trick by then appeared and back.
But no,
I'm just here.
That's object permanence.
If,
if I win under here and then the people said where the hell they go,
classes over that would show a lack of object permanence.
So adults have object permanence.
P and g is very interesting claim is that kids don't,
um,
before six month olds,
Piaget observed you take an object,
the kid likes like a rattle,
you hide it,
you put it behind something.
It's like it's gone.
And he claimed a child where he thinks it's just gone.
Things don't continue to exist when I'm not looking at them anymore.
Um,
and so he noticed that there were surprised by Peekaboo NPH.
His claim was one reason why there's a prize at peekaboo as you go,
you know,
we're going to kick,
you're looking at a kid because my anger,
oh,
peekaboo.
And he closed it.
You cover your face and the kid says he's gone.
Peekaboo.
Oh,
there he is.
He's gone.
And he really,
you know,
that's the claim.
Piaget also discovered an older children fail at a task is known as the a not B
task.
And,
uh,
Peter Gray in a psychology textbook refers to it as the changing hiding places
problem,
which is probably a better name for it.
And here's the idea.
You take a nine month old and for Piaggi at nine month old is just starting to
make sense of objects and an end or permanence.
You take an object and you put it here in a,
in a cop where the kid can't see if it's in the cup.
So the kid,
if you're at a kid will reach for it.
You do it again,
reach for it.
That's point.
Then you take your,
move it over here.
The IJ observed kids would still reach for this.
It's like they're not smart enough to figure it out.
It's not there anymore.
Even if they see it move.
And this was more evidence that they just did,
don't understand objects.
And this,
the,
this thing takes a lot of time and learning to develop the next stage is the pre
operational stage.
Um,
the pre operational stage.
The child starts off grasping the world only in a physical way,
in a sensory motor way.
But when he gets to the pre-operational period,
the capacity to represent the world,
to have the world inside your head comes into being,
but it's limited and it's limited in a couple of striking ways.
One way in which is limited is that true winner egocentric.
Now egocentrism has a,
uh,
a meaning and common English,
which means to be selfish.
Piaget meant in a more technical way.
He claimed a children litter at this age literally can't understand that others
can see the world differently from them.
So one of his demonstrations was the three mountains task.
You have three mountains over there.
You put a child on one side of the mountains and you ask them to draw it.
And I'm like a four or five year old can do it easily,
but then you ask him to draw it as it would appear from the other side.
And Cherlynn find is extraordinarily difficult.
They find it very difficult to grasp the world as another person might see it.
Um,
another significant finding Piaget had about this phase of development concerns,
what's called conservation.
And the notion of conservation is that there's ways to transform things such
that some aspects of the change but others remained the same.
So for instance,
um,
if you take a glass of water and you pour it into another glass that's shallow
or tall,
it won't change the amount of water you have.
If you take a bunch of pennies and you spread them out,
you don't get more pennies.
But kids according to Piaget don't know that.
And this is one of the real cool demonstrations.
Any of you have access to a four or five year old,
um,
a sibling or something.
Do not take one without permission.
But if you have access to a four or five or you couldn't do this yourself,
this is what it looks like.
I,
the first one has no sound.
A second one is going to be sound.
It's going to come on at the end,
but there's two rows of checker.
She asked the kid
which one has more?
Okay,
kid says they're the same.
Then she doesn't.
Now she has him.
Which one has more
that of that?
So that's really stupid and,
and it's,
it's amazing.
It's an amazing finding.
Kids will do this and it's a robust finding.
Here's another example.
So they're the same.
So it's a cool finding of that stage suggesting a limitation in how you deal and
make sense of the world.
The next phase,
concrete operations from seven to 12,
you can solve the conservation problem,
but still you're limited to the extent you're capable of abstract reasoning.
So the mathematical notions of infinity or logical notions like logical
entailment are beyond a child of this age.
The child is able to do a lot,
but still is to some extent stuck in the concrete world.
And then finally at around age 12,
um,
you could get abstracts and scientific reasoning and this is the Piaggi Eddie
and theory in very brief form.
Now paij fared a lot better than did Freud or Skinner,
um,
for several reasons.
One reason is these are interesting and falsifiable claims about child
development.
So claims that about failure of conservation in children at different ages
because we easily tested and systematically tested.
And in fact there was a lot of support for them.
Piaggi had a rich theoretical framework pulling together all sorts of
observations and different ways wrote many,
many books and articles and articulated as theory very richly.
And most of all,
I think he had some really striking findings before Piaget.
Nobody noticed these conservation findings before.
Piaggi nobody noticed that babies had this problem tracking and understanding
objects at the same time.
However,
there are limitations in Piaget's theory.
Some of these limitations are theoretical.
Um,
it's an interesting question as to whether he really explains how a child goes
from a concrete thinker to an abstract thinker or how would he goes from not
having object permanence to understanding object permanence.
There's methodological limitations.
Piaget was really big into question and answer,
but one problem with this is that children aren't very good with language and
this might lead you to underestimate how much they know and this is particularly
a problem.
The younger you get.
Um,
methodology is going to loom heavy in the discussion of any science and that
includes psychology.
Often 90% of the game is discovering a clever method through which to test your
hypotheses.
Well,
we're going to talk a little bit about that regarding babies.
I'll give you another example from a very different domain.
There was a set of scientist interested in studying tickling.
So when you tickle somebody under what circumstances will a laugh,
where do you have to take all of them,
can even tickle yourself.
Does it have to be a surprise?
And so on.
It turns out very difficult to study this in a lab.
You're not going to have your experimental credit.
You come into lab say,
okay,
our undergraduate student,
uh,
and,
and in fact,
an example of,
of a methodological attempt was done by Henry met at University of Pennsylvania
who builds a tickle Michigan,
which was this box with these two giant hands that win.
And um,
and this was a failure because people can not go near the tickle machine
development,
convulsing and laughter.
But we will discuss when we have a lecture on laughter,
um,
a bit of the tickle sciences
and finally there's factual.
What are infants and children really know.
It's possible that due to the methodological limitations of Piaggi,
he systematically underestimated what children and babies now.
And in fact,
I'll present some evidence suggesting that this is in fact that this is the
case.
Um,
so I want to introduce you to the modern science of infant cognition.
Inven cognition has been something studied for a very long time and there is a
certain view that has had behind it a tremendous philosophical and psychological
consensus.
And it's summarized in this onion headline here.
And the idea is that that babies are stupid.
Um,
that'd babies really don't know much about the world.
Now,
the work that this onion headline is satirizing is the reason studies,
which I'm going to talk about suggested on the contrary,
babies might be smarter than you think.
And,
and to discover the intelligence of babies,
we have to ourselves be pretty smart in developing different techniques to study
what a baby knows.
You can't ask you questions,
babies can't talk.
Um,
you could look at what it does,
but babies are not very coordinated or skilled.
So you need to use clever methods.
One Glover method is to look at their brainwaves.
This,
this trial on the right die during testing.
It was a tragic,
a crushed by the way to the electrodes.
Um,
he's happy though.
you can study their brainwaves.
One of the few things babies can do is they can suck on a pacifier and you might
think,
well,
how can you learn anything from that?
Well,
for instance,
you could build machines that when babies suck on a pacifier,
they hear music or they hear language and then you could look at how much they
suck on a pacifier to determine what they like.
But undeniably we know most of our,
we got most of our knowledge about babies from studies of they're looking times.
Um,
that's one thing babies can do.
They can look,
and I'm,
I have up here,
this is a picture of Elizabeth Spelke [inaudible] who's a developmental
psychologist who's developed the most research on looking at babies looking
times and what you can learn from them.
And I have here two ways you could learn from looking.
One is preference.
So for instance,
suppose you want to know for whatever reason,
do babies liked the looks of dogs or cats?
Well,
you could put a baby down,
have a picture of a dog here,
a picture of a cat here and see which one the baby looks at.
Babies can move their eyes and that could tell you something.
Do babies distinguished pretty faces from ugly faces?
Well put a pretty face here and ugly phase here.
See if the baby prefers to look at the pretty one.
Uh,
you can also do habituation and surprise and much of the studies I'm going to
talk about here involve habituation and surprise.
Habituation is a fancy word for boredom.
What you do is you show a baby something over and over again.
Now remember from behaviorism the baby will learn.
This isn't very interesting.
Then you show the baby something different.
If the baby really sees it as different,
the baby will look longer and you could use that as a measure of what babies
find different.
For instance,
suppose you want to know if a baby can tell green from red.
Well,
you could show the baby a green patch,
a green patch of green patch of green patch,
maybe you'll get bored then a red patch.
If they all look the same to the baby,
the baby will just continue to tune out.
But if the red looks different to baby will perk up.
And this is in fact one way they studied color vision in babies.
Surprise as related to this.
You could show babies something that shouldn't happen if babies are like,
if babies also think it shouldn't happen,
they might look longer.
And essentially what happens is scientists do magic tricks to explore this very
thing.
And to start with some real examples,
a lot of this infant research has gone back to the Phd in question of object
permanence,
asking,
is it really true?
Babies don't know that objects remain that objects,
uh,
remain even when they're out of sight.
So one very simple study by,
uh,
by spelled [inaudible] had babies shown a block with a bar going back and forth.
Like that sort of bar just goes back and forth.
Now there's something you do that's so obvious,
you probably don't even know you're doing it.
When you see a display like that where you assume is there,
there's a bar there and what that means,
there's something in the middle that you've never seen before.
But of course if you were a simple perceptual creature,
you would just see that there'd be a bar on top and a bar in Nevato.
You wouldn't expect anything in the middle of that.
He never saw anything in the middle.
So what you do then is you show babies this and then you show them either B or
c.
And if we do this with adults,
you expect BC is almost a joke.
And in fact,
babies respond the same way.
Babies expect her to be an entire complete bar and our surprise and look longer
at the broken bar.
Um,
other studies,
some of them,
um,
well here's another study by Renee by arch hall looking at the same thing in a
different way.
You show the baby,
say a six month old,
a stage with a block on it,
then a screen rises and obscures the block.
Now if the baby's expect the blocked is still be there,
they should think the block should,
should stop the screen.
On the other hand,
if out of sight,
out of mind,
they should expect the screen to keep going.
So what you do is you set up a couple of displays.
One word a block keeps is stopped.
The other one where you take,
you take this away for trap door and it keeps going.
And as you see,
the baby screams when this happens,
that doesn't really happen,
but they do.
But they do look longer.
Um,
one final example of an object permanence study,
um,
if some of this work's been done at Yale and Karen winds lab where they look at
babies understanding of addition and subtraction.
And a lot of it is done with real objects,
but there's also animated versions.
So here is an animated example.
Yeah.
Babies.
Babies are surprised.
They expect two minus one equals equal one and went to minus one equals two or
three or zero.
They look lamara indicating surprise.
And even six month olds are sensitive to these rudimentary facts of arithmetic
telling us something about their mathematical knowledge,
but also telling us something about that they expect things to remain when
they're out of sight.
Now,
this research suggests that infants understanding of the physical world is there
from the very start,
but at the same time,
not entirely.
We know there's certain things babies don't know.
Here's an example.
Suppose you show babies this,
you have a block here and they have something above there floating in midair.
Babies find this surprising,
even six month olds find a surprising it violates gravity,
but six month olds aren't smart enough to know that a block just stuck over here
is also surprising.
12 month olds will think that it should fall.
Six month olds don't,
and even 12 month olds don't find anything weird about this.
While adults are sophisticated enough to understand that that should that an
unstable configuration and should fall over.
So although some things are built in,
some things develop,
and this raises the question of how do we explain development?
How do we explain when babies come to know things that he didn't originally
know?
Well,
one answer is a neuro maturation,
growth,
growth of the brain.
Um,
most add up,
most of the neurons you've had,
you have now in your head right now,
you had when you were in your mother's uterus,
what happens in development isn't for the most part,
the growth of new neurons.
It's for the most part,
pruning getting rid of neurons.
So the neural structures change radically as babies kind of get rid of excess
neurons through development.
At the same time though,
um,
connections between neurons grow like crazy and the,
and there's this process of synaptic growth where there's the connections across
different synapses,
peaks at about two years.
Finally,
remember myelination where you sort of get this fatty sheath over your neuron to
make it more effective.
That also happens through development and,
and in fact,
it goes through development and even teenagers are not fully myelinated in
particular.
They're not fully myelinated in their frontal lobes.
Recall,
at frontal lobes are involved in things like restraint and willpower.
Um,
and so it could be the problem is the baby's brain doesn't develop yet.
Another possibility is there's problems with inhibition.
This is related again to the frontal lobes and this comes up with a not be
error.
So remember the baby reaches,
reaches,
reaches his move,
reach,
follow up,
keeps reaching the same place.
And it could be that babies don't know anything about objects,
but another possibility is once you do something,
it's kind of hard to stop.
It takes a bit of control to stop.
And there's all sorts of independent evidence that babies lack this control a
part of their brain that could control certain behaviors,
um,
is just not active yet.
Um,
there's a very nice illustration of inhibitory problems from a Simpsons episode
that actually sort of covers anything you might want to know about.
Developmental differences
basically may sum up much a developmental psychology that the child,
that the child essentially,
um,
he does a,
it's moved.
You go no and he keeps going for it.
And there's some evidence that's true.
Adele diamond who studied this fines that are low kids reach for AA.
They look for be as if the,
they know it's there,
but it can't stop themselves from reaching.
And we'll continue this theme a little bit later.
Finally,
it might be kids don't know things.
Some things you got to learn,
and this is true in all sorts of domains in the social world and the economic
world and the political world.
And it's true as well in the physical world.
In fact,
there's some things even adults don't know.
So,
um,
so here's a study by Michael mccloskey with college students.
Here's the idea.
You have a tube,
a transparent,
a Tuba,
a hollow tube,
and at the top of the tube you throw a ball through.
So whips through the tube and comes out.
Question is what happens to it?
Does it go in the path of a or does it go in the path of B without looking
around?
Who votes for a WHO votes for B?
Here's the weird thing.
Whenever I do this at Yale,
everybody gets the damn thing right
at Johns Hopkins,
50 50 when for a and B
I got to get a better demo.
But anyway,
college students not here show systematic biases of incorrect physical
intuitions.
Here's a twist and if you were,
if you,
if you found people who were less wonderful than you all and ask them,
you'd get a lot of people saying the curving thing but nears the twist.
Ask somebody,
what if you took a tube and you squirted water through it?
Where would the water though?
Nobody chooses B.
Everybody knows the water would continue in a straight line suggesting that that
when you have experience that helps you out but an absence of experience,
you're kind of lost.
Um,
we've talked about the physical world.
What about the social world?
What about the world of people?
While there's a lot of research on this as well,
babies start off with some social preferences.
If you take newborn babies,
it's very hard to do research with newborn babies actually because of the
consent procedure and everything.
So most of this work has done in France.
We're like,
where they have no laws at all.
They just rush into women,
give birth and aggression and says we are psychologists.
And then they do experiments.
On the babies and it's terrific.
And this is like one of them where they compare baby's looking at this versus
this baby's like the one that lasts like a face.
These are newborns.
Um,
there's some preferences with humans and with other primaries to favor faces.
Babies are also social animals too.
So there are natural mimics.
Um,
Andrew melts off for instance,
has found that if you go to a newborn baby and if you get it,
if you find a newborn baby,
this is the first thing,
first thing you should do,
stick your face right up to newborn baby and toys and stick your tongue out.
And melts are fines that babies more often than not,
stick their tongues out back,
um,
suggesting some sort of social connection from one person to another and then
later on babies are,
mimics babies more often than not.
We'll copy the face next to them.
Now these,
the nature of these responses,
this preferring faces,
this sort of mimicry is a matter of debate.
There's a lot of research going on asking how smarter babies can we see you?
Some of the same methods.
Um,
two,
that we've looked at it for the physical world.
Look at the social world.
And to illustrate one of the studies,
I will tell you about a study that I did with Valerie.
Cool Meyer and Karen Win.
And so what we tested was nine month olds and 12 month olds.
And we showed the movies sort of sitting down or seeing a movie where one
character is going to help abolish,
achieve a goal and another character's going to hinder the ball.
And then we're going to see whether they expect the ball to approach,
um,
the one that helped it versus the one that hindered it.
So this is what a baby would see.
This is literally the same movie a baby would see in the experiment.
The thing is for these sorts of experiments,
there's a lot of that control.
So something that's a square in one movie will be a triangle in another movie,
something that's on the top.
And one movie will be,
uh,
on the bottom and another movie.
So this is an example movie,
but this is what babies would see.
And they see this over and over again.
And the question is would they expect babies,
weed,
babies,
expect them went to approach the one that helped it
or approach to one that hindered it.
And what we find is statistically babies look longer when Shawna movie where it
approach just the one that hindered at versus helped him.
And this we take as preliminary evidence that um,
that they,
they have a social interpretation.
They see this movie as you see this movie in terms of helping and hindering and
somebody's going to somebody that helped it versus hindered it.
You could then ask,
this makes a prediction that babies should themselves prefer the creature who's
to help her versus to hinder and to explore this.
A graduate student in his department,
Kylie Hamlin has started a series of studies where they sh they show babies
three dimensional scenes and then give them the characters and see which one
they reach for.
So here's video so you can see how this experiment is that
okay?
Oh,
next trial is from a different study.
Different things were used and the baby's given a choice.
And,
um,
one thing to know methodologically is the person giving a choice is blind to
this study.
And blind here is a technical term,
meaning she had no idea what the baby's saw.
And the point of this is to avoid either intentional or unintentional,
sort of trying to get the answer you want.
She couldn't do that because she didn't know what the right answer is.
So here's what the baby would say.
So,
so this suggests that some social understanding,
maybe they're from the very start.
This evidence is tentative,
very controversial,
but
now I want to raise a huge developmental puzzle.
And the puzzle is there are some ways in which babies are not just babies,
but young children are very clueless when it comes to people.
And so I have a film clip here of two very nice studies showing babies,
ignorant,
sorry,
young children's ignorance of other people.
I'll show you the studies and then we'll briefly discuss what they mean
before discussing that example a little bit more detail.
Um,
any,
any questions?
What are your questions?
Yes.
And back.
Yeah.
Typically,
I'm,
I don't know for those particular children,
but typically on those tasks,
three year olds and young four year olds tend to fail and around the age of four
or five kids tend to succeed or sort of a,
a period around the age of four,
four and a half where kids make the transition from,
from a failure to success.
Okay.
The question by the way,
was when new children in that video,
when were,
what were the ages of children,
uh,
who failed and who passed?
Yes.
Tomorrow.
Um,
the question of whether discriminant conditioning has been used with babies to
explore what sort of concepts they have.
I don't know.
Does anybody,
it has been,
um,
the,
Colleen answered and said that,
that it's not as effective as other methods.
Part of the problem with using operant conditioning with babies is it's
difficult to get him to behave in any systematic way.
So they're looking,
time measures tend to be more,
more subtle.
Okay.
Um,
any other questions?
Oh yes.
Those young boys,
the rocket ship one versus the
Oh,
um,
the question of why they chose the baby that the kids chose the rocket ship one
as opposed to the Rafaelle one.
Um,
it wasn't what they were interested in an experiment.
My bed is when they can,
when they've toes the stickers,
they had a pretty good sense of why of which ones the boys would prefer in those
studies.
Um,
the question of why a boy you might prefer one sort of sticker and you might get
a different response if a girl is going to come up later when we discuss
different theories of sex differences.
But that was something I think they were just assuming in the study to get it
off the ground.
Okay.
Um,
okay.
There's a huge debate over what's going on there.
And if you listen at the end to the psychologist summarizing the data,
the psychologist had a very good and very clear and strong idea of what was
going on.
It was that children need to know more about mines.
The children don't know about that.
You can do something with the intent to deceive.
They don't understand that somebody could choose what you chose in a malicious
way.
This is possible.
This is one respectable theory,
but the alternative is
they have the right knowledge,
but they suffer from problems with inhibition.
So consider both studies.
The first study to one of the deceptive dolls with the big shoes and little
shoes is actually fairly difficult and it's possible that children kind of got
overwhelmed with it.
And when asked,
um,
what would the mother think,
who the mother would think stole the food,
responded with,
who really stole the food?
And there's some pull towards the right answer that makes this task difficult.
The second one,
the second study illustrates this issue even more clearly.
Take the boy who kept failing.
He kept pointing to the rocket ship and mean monkey kept taking it away.
Okay?
It's possible.
The heat genuinely didn't know what to do and he wasn't smart enough to
understand that he needed to point to the other one.
But it's also possible that it's a homer Simpson like effect where when asked to
point to what he wants,
he just couldn't help but point to the one he wanted and that the extra work it
takes to lie,
um,
was beyond him.
And in support of the second alternative,
um,
even adults find these tasks involving lying and deception more difficult.
There were slower at them,
we make more mistakes then,
then,
um,
then Tafta don't involve lying and deception.
So I'm raising this not to solve the problem,
you'll read more about it in the Peter Gray textbook and more about it in the
Norton readings on development.
But just to raise this as an interesting area of debate,
another interesting area of debate
is what's the relationship between different sorts of development.
So I started off with Pij Npha like Freud believed in general across the board,
changes in how children think.
An alternative though is that they're separate modules.
And this is a view depend,
uh,
developed again by Noam Chomsky and also by the philosopher of mind Jerry Fodor
who claim that the whole idea of a child developing as a single story is
mistaken what you get instead.
Is there separate prewired systems for reasoning about the world?
Um,
these systems have some built in knowledge and they have to do some learning,
but the learning pattern varies from system to system and there's a separateness
to them.
Why should we take this view seriously?
Well,
one reason is that there are developmental disorders that seemed to involve
damage to one system but not to another.
And the classic case of this is a disorder known as autism.
And Autism is something I've always found a fascinating disorder for many
reasons.
It's actually why I entered psychology.
I started off working with children with autism and it could be taken as a
striking illustration of how the social part of your brain is distinct from
other parts of your brand.
So what autism is a disorder that strikes about one and a thousand people,
mostly boys.
And the dominant problems.
Concern consists of a lack of social connectedness,
problems with language problems dealing with people and more generally,
uh,
problems.
What the psychologist Simon Baron Cohen has described as mine,
blindness in that autistic people show no impairments dealing with the physical
world.
They show no impairments on.
They don't necessarily show any impairments on mathematical skills or spatial
skills,
but they have a lot of problems with people.
Now,
many autistic children,
um,
have no language.
They're totally shut off from society,
but even some of them who learn language and who managed to get some sort of
independent life nevertheless will suffer from a severe social impairment.
And this could be shown in all sorts of ways.
A simple experiment develop.
I Simon Baron Cohen goes like this,
you show this to three and four year olds.
There's four candies there and you say,
this is Charlie in the middle,
which chocolate?
We'll Charlie's hake for most children.
And most of you,
I hope the answer's pretty clear.
This one,
autistic children will often just shrug and say,
how can I know?
Because they don't instinctively appreciate that people's interest and desires
tend to be attuned to where they're looking.
Another sort of task,
which is a task that has been done hundreds,
perhaps thousands of times,
is known as the false belief task and here's the idea.
You show the child the following situation.
There's a doll named Maxine and Maxine.
He puts the ball in the cupboard,
Maxie leaves and a second doll enters the second doll,
takes the ball out of the cupboard and puts it under the bed.
Yeah,
Maxie comes back and the question is where will Maxy look for the ball?
Now this is a question about your understanding about minds.
The question of where is the ball really is a question about the physical world.
Everyone can solve it,
but this question is hard.
The right answer is Max woke.
Maxi will look in the cupboard even though it's not really there because Max
Max,
he has a false belief about the world.
Three year olds find this difficult to year olds find is difficult.
Four year olds and five year olds are able to pass this task.
Normal adults are able to pass this task.
Children with autism have serious problems and often people have autism who are
otherwise very high functioning will fail this task.
They'll say,
oh,
he must think he's going to check under the bed.
Any questions about um,
about autism?
Yeah.
Yes.
Good question.
It isn't.
This is,
they're both,
they're both experiment designed to tap and appreciation of false belief.
The deception one with the,
with the shoes and everything looked at it in the course of deception.
Can you understand that?
A mother might think it's that person even though it's really that person and
our kid failed.
This is a sort of stripped down version without all the fanciness,
but it has exactly the same thing.
Okay.
Yes.
Nobody knows.
Um,
but there is a theory which won't answer your question,
but we'll put it in a broader context.
Simon Baron Cohen argues that there are certain abilities that tend to be more
sequestered for males and other abilities that are more sequestered,
more focused on females.
Um,
social abilities he argues tend to be more female than male.
So the way baron puts it provocatively is to be a man is to suffer from a very
mild form of autism.
Um,
the idea is then that autistic individuals suffer from what he calls extreme
male brains.
And as such,
it stands to reason that they'd be more sample from the male population than the
female population.
That's such an interesting issue that again,
when we returned to talk about sex differences,
we'll look at that in a little bit more detailed to see if it,
if it's supported by the evidence.
Yes.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
Tell me that is the severity of autism.
It's an interesting question.
Um,
the question is how do you think about the severity of autism with regard to
developmental stages and sort of surprisingly,
autism can't really be thought of in that way.
So it's not like an adult with autism is like a three year old or two year old
in some way.
Something like autism with autism isn't like any child at all.
Um,
and he normally developing child at all.
So it's not really a developmental,
uh,
it's not really a developmental delay in the way that it might make sense to
think about certain forms or retardation.
On the other hand,
when we think about how severe autism is,
we do look at things like how much language does the person have and in that
sense it is related to development.
Okay.
Yes.
Overcompensate.
Um,
the majority of people with autism,
it's a good question.
The question is
what are the chances of somebody with autism would be able to overcome their
deficiencies?
Um,
autism's a funny disorder and there's a lot of media publication,
immediate presentation often to people who are showcased in a media tend to be
very exceptional.
So there was a woman temple Grandin who's autistic and has anybody here heard of
temple Grandin?
Um,
she wrote some wonderful books about her experience as an autistic person,
but she is very unusual.
So a lot depends to answer your question,
how one defines autism and whether one includes Asperger's syndrome,
which is a limited sense,
a more mild syndrome as a form of autism.
The answer is that the majority of people with autism have severe problems and
will not.
And at this stage with this level of therapy will not lead a normal.
More specifically what I meant was when you showed the example of rain that,
Yup.
Um,
you said that most people have autism.
Are they exceptional at math and analytical skills or are they just better?
The question is about so called autistic savant.
So rain man,
the character played by Dustin Hoffman had extraordinary mathematical abilities
and some people with autism have extraordinary artistic abilities,
are mathematical abilities or a musical abilities.
Um,
and these are amazing.
It's an amazing question why they have it.
But this is a very small minority.
This is a very,
it's,
it's fascinating that happens at all that you can have severe damage but
compensated with some powerful skill.
Now I know,
and I'm answering your question,
I think in a better way,
but it's actually very rare.
Most people have autism do not have any exceptional abilities that go along with
it.
Another question is,
if you believe in modules,
if there are modules,
what are they?
And so far when reviewing the developmental data,
we've talked about two of them,
physics and people,
an object module and the social module,
but other people have argued that there was a special module in your brain for
dealing with artifacts.
That is things like tables and chairs and cars and forks.
Some people have argued there's a module for sociology for dealing with human
groups,
races and classes and so on.
Some have even argued that there is an intuitive biology,
a common sense,
biological understanding of the world that's separate from um,
from your understanding of people and physics.
And in fact the most dominant proponent of the view is our very own.
Frank Kyle Master Morse College at Yale were strongly defended the notion of a
intuitive biological module.
Final question just to raise,
I've talked in terms of the modular view,
but
there might also be profound general differences between children,
adults,
not just specific to how you think about objects or how you think about people
or how you think about this or how you think about that,
but rather than more general.
And one claim which we're going to return to briefly next class when we talk
about language is that there's a very,
very big difference between a creature that doesn't have language and a creature
that does.
And part of the claim is that learning a language,
learning to speak reconfigures the human brain in such a way that is really
exceptional and that has no parallel in any other species.
And this is an interesting claim.
And um,
one we'll talk about.
Um,
finally I want to end with an example from Stephen Jay Gould.
suppose you hate development.
You hate developmental psychology.
You hate babies,
you hate children,
they're not cute,
they're ugly.
You don't want to have him,
you don't want to study them.
You're,
you're annoyed that we have to discuss them.
Fine.
But there are reasons to study development even if you are not interested in
children,
because sometimes developmental studies and developmental date and developmental
science can inform questions about adults.
And Stephen Jay Gould has a very nice example of this.
He asked the question,
is a zebra,
a black animal with white stripes or a white animal with black stripes?
Now,
you could look at adult zebras all day long and you're never going to figure
this out.
But if you want to know the answer,
and I knew it,
but I forget what it is,
it doesn't matter.
But if you wanted to know it,
you could.
You look at development and you'd watch the embryological development of a
zebra,
and that's how you learn to answer to your question.
In fact,
I'll end with a nice quote.
Um,
this is by the famous biologist Darcy Thompson who wrote the book on growth and
form.
And it's sort of,
uh,
the motto of many developmental psychologists and many evolutionary
psychologists.
So I'll end with this.
Everything is the way it is because it got that way.
Okay,
I'll see you next week.